Congress they got a bad rap Congress
right everybody hates them seven percent
approval that's actually pretty good for
them when they get the seven percent but
they did something unanimously in
Congress they never do sign unanimously
so you know this has to be on the right
side of history they're going to stop
social security payments for Nazis yeah
they were paying Nazis we've been paying
Nazis Social Security we kicked the
Nazis out even the Nazis that came here
that somehow falsify documents that we
found out they came here that we kicked
them out and we've been paying Social
Security benefits to Nazis I've seen a
couple examples of is there's a 90 year
old guy those living in Croatia a former
Nazi we've been giving him fifteen
hundred dollars a month this is just one
of several examples of this I waited
we're paying Nazis we've been giving
Nazis Social Security you know every
time something comes up Obamacare or any
sort of budget battle about all the
Social Security we're gonna lose Social
Security well we're gonna save a little
bit of money now because we're gonna
stop giving Nazis social security so yes
Congress stepped up I tell Vic is about
four people left that are actually
getting these payments but I just think
this whole this all story it's just like
everything it's just every day or once
how did this ever even get past oh yeah
a former Nazis let's give them Social
Security who passed this thing in the
first place number one number two it's
nice to see our Congress actually do
saying but it's just so funny they can
only come together on something that
sounds so absolutely [ __ ] bonkers
that really Nazis getting Social
Security it sounds like a science
fiction movie but sadly it's not anyway
so we are not going to be giving Nazis
social security payments anymore so
that's a little bit more that maybe we
can put into education or that we could
put into roads or into cleaning the air
something like that but just kidding
we're gonna put it into bombs and things
of that nature uh social security Nazis
Nazis it Nazis in Croatia are getting
Social Security money and uh you know I
I what what else can I possibly add to
that we normally do these one hundred
forty seconds but Nazis Social Security
amending this thing right now